Harvard researcher Todd Rose is working
to change how we think about success he
co-wrote the new book dark horse
achieving success through the pursuit of
fulfillment it tracks the unlikely paths
of individuals who triumph against the
odds
they include Jenny McCormack who became
a respected astronomer without a college
degree degree and sound engineer Susan
Rodgers who recorded with Prince before
becoming a college professor the book
highlights their stories to quote help
you become the best version of yourself
Todd good morning good morning what's
wrong with the way we think about
success well I think that for most of us
when we think about success it's pretty
narrow and we end up think about things
like wealth status power and we sort of
think that you have to choose between
that and being happy and dark horses
show us that you actually don't have to
choose and what do you have to do if
you're a dark horse what are you what's
at the center of your life the secret is
prioritizing personal fulfillment over
more conventional notions of success if
that's the case and I'm just coming up
in the world what's the difference
between prioritizing personal
fulfillment and just being flaky we
found in our research it's about taking
personal responsibility for your choices
right so all the men and women we
studied they never shirk responsibility
they always were willing to sacrifice
for fulfillment and I think as a parent
I often think about this for my own kids
asking that question you know if they
want to be an actor and they're living
in Hollywood with seven roommates and
you know working two jobs that's
responsibility right they want me to
fund their life so you're thinking okay
maybe this isn't gonna work out for you
this Hollywood dream but I like what you
said in your book these Dark Horse's are
ignored until they get success and then
they're called inspiring right and you
were a dark horse you were twenty-year
you dropped out of out of college you
didn't and then you had two kids by the
age of twenty and the people were
looking at you going I don't know about
Todd yeah no I was pretty lost at that
we relied on welfare to take care of my
two kids it was actually my dad who gave
me this piece of advice that changed
everything he said if I wanted something
better I had to figure out what really
motivated me and I had to stay close to
that and that advice changed my path
completely and that letting me get a GED
go to college and eventually end up at
Harvard where I get to study what makes
people take and you write about the game
of judgment that helps people find their
true motivations what is that you know
it's just a simple way to figure out you
know what motivates you and let me give
you the short version here you give out
the things that you enjoy doing and ask
yourself why right so if you enjoy
football is it the competition is it
being outdoors is it the camaraderie
that comes with team sports the more you
think about those things the more you
know what really moves you and if you
ask yourself that question off enough it
will reveal your broader motives and
that will put you on a path to
fulfillment and you see no such thing as
one size fits all fulfillment which I
thought was an interesting concept
ya know look we've tried that right
everybody's different and as soon as we
start appreciating that we can build
systems that allow everyone to be
successful and happy speaking of
building those systems how do you do
this you know scale way other than just
person by person you know what I think
twenty years ago it would have been
really hard to do now if you take
something like education we absolutely
can personalize it right we can take our
kids individuality seriously which I
find sort of odd is that we've figured
out how to personalize almost all other
aspects of our life but when it comes to
our kids education
we're shockingly sort of okay with the
status quo but we shouldn't be and so
how can parents encourage their kids and
let them live their full potential
without giving them what they need in
the life lessons that they need look I
think it comes down to one really
important thing especially when they're
young which is they need to figure out
what really matters to them and what
motivates them and we can help them by
asking but you think about as parents
we actually don't ask our kids that very
often we spend a lot of time telling
them what should matter yeah I'm very
little time helping them figure it out
for themselves yeah you said people
always think you have to choose the
behavior between what you like or what
you must do and you're saying you should
really focus on what you like yeah and
if you prioritize good wait but when
you're trying to support yourself and
make a living and survive sometimes you
can't do what you like to do you know
and I think that actually this darkhorse
mindset I believe matters even more for
people who don't have a safety net right
the people who have to say hit a home
run on every choice they make because
there's no room for error right
because I think their knowing who you
are knowing what really motivates you
and know how to make choices off of that
can make all the difference in the world
well it's not just a popular Katy Perry
song now it's a must-read book as well
dark force great to have you here when
that was your Katy Perry song idea now
you know Todd Todd Rose thank you so
much and Dark Horse is on sale now